bassam où en est on aujourd'hui dans
quel état d'esprit se trouvent les
tunisiens écoutez devra être tunisiens
sont toujours dans l'attentât près cet
événement historique beaucoup ont parlé
d'une deuxième révolution comme celle
que les tunisiens on peut connaître il y
a dix ans hier un rassemblement a eu
lieu devant le parlement un
rassemblement à l'appel du parti ennahda
ou les députés ont essayé d'accéder au
parlement mes instructions de la part de
carthage et les militaires étaient là
pour protéger le site aucun député n'a
accès au parlement il avait eu des
affrontements entre pro- ennahda est un
anti ennahdha et beaucoup de réactions à
ce sujet je vous propose dans l'écouté
certaine qu'on l'a plus recueillie hier
devant le parlement
hier le président lorsqu'il s'est
exprimé il nous a rendu notre pays il
nous a rendu la tunisie il ne me l'a pas
rendu à moi il l'a vendue à mes enfants
il l'a rendu à cette jeunesse qu'on a
laissé tomber c'est la vérité c'est ça
qui nous a donné depuis dix ans ennahda
nous à gouverner rien ne s'est passé
le pays continue à sombrer a chuté c'est
à dire que c'est quelque chose qui ne
convient pas du tout et nous nous sommes
venus pour chasser nada nous au sein du
mouvement ennahdha nous attendons l'avis
de l'ensemble des magistrats des
syndicats de magistrats ainsi que l'avis
des doyens des magistrats du pays
ce jour symbolise la division entre le
vrai et le faux contre la légalité et
l'illégalité nous aujourd'hui moi en
tant que personne je me soulève pour
soutenir tous ceux qui se soulèvent pour
la vérité je soutiens la légalité la loi
la constitution le parlement élu par le
peuple
c'est parlement qui doit être respectée
continue sa feuille de route il annoncé
hier lors d'une réunion qui s'est tenue
à carthage hier soit qu'ils n'étaient
pas putschistes et que sa décision
respecter la constitution tunisienne
de nouvelles mesures ont été prises
notamment le gel de certains services
publics à savoir l'administration
centrale ou encore les services
extérieurs un gel de deux jours
couvre feu lui a été modifié passant de
6 heures à 20 heures à 5 heures à 19
heures les limogeages continue le
présent de république après avoir limogé
son premier ministre a limogé hier le
ministre de la défense on a appris que
le ministre des affaires étrangères a eu
une longue conversation avec le
président wade
on ne sait pas exactement si ces dix
pendant cette conversation on peut
penser que les mises et les affaires
étrangères a apporté son soutien au
président de la république la haute
autorité magistral ici en tunisie est
toujours en discussion concernant cette
décision du président de la république
certains hommes d'affaires et certains
politiciens notamment des députés du
parti islamiste ennahda eux sont
interdits de voyager et puis toutes ces
décisions ont été mises au journal
officiel par le président de la
république est tunisien attend toujours
pour cette nouvelle journée de nouvelles
décisions quant à cantal ce parcours
décidée par le président de la
république
merci beaucoup bassem h&b pour toutes
ces précisions en direct de tunis